good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend Friday Friday getting
down on Friday that is right it is it is
it is it is Friday
congratulations
congratulations to you the most unwell
mcclurgia that we've seen in a while
honestly I don't even know if today's
I'm not even hungover I had like a
cocktail and a half at dinner
um this has just been like a difficult
week on my body I don't know why I did a
lot this week one it was Halloween we
traveled I was being an aunt I'm just
like not getting good sleep I hate to be
that girl but I do have my period like
I'm just like I'm I'm really deceased
and
what I hate to be I hate for you to be
that girl look I just I had it was
important like to explain to people like
why I'm feeling unwell it's like I'm on
day two like I'm not doing well okay you
know yeah I'm sorry are you triggered no
I guess it's like I guess it's better on
a podcast and like people really know
everything that's going on with us every
day so like that is I guess you might as
well know they might as well know
Jermaine maybe my pet peeve only relates
to Instagram stories you know yeah when
people like can't post their Instagram
stories they're like sorry I'm an M.I.A
like I have a period like no it's okay
but I felt like it was nice it was
necessary to drop it today I think
because you were talking about the
strains of the week the physical strains
yeah so I have my period so just wanted
everyone to know like yeah my parents um
I'm feeling
good-ish we did have a fun night which
we'll discuss but we're kind of like
Freaky Friday right now yes because I'm
dressed like Claudia actually I copied
her outfit I saw you in a boy's lie set
I'm obsessed when you came to Florida
over the summer and I was like I need
that it's so cute and I finally got one
that suits me and Air Force ones of
course and I was wearing my hair in like
your new 90s chignon but I saw myself on
the Monitor and I don't think it was
suiting me let's talk about boys lie
because I have actually like a funny
story okay so I have like a personal
boy's light is a brand it's the brand
that I'm wearing right now it's at
revolve I don't know where else it is I
have like a personal policy it actually
like I get really bothered when PR
packages show up to my house when a
brand like hasn't reached out didn't ask
for my address I don't know how they
acquire my address they obviously got it
in some shady way like it really bothers
me well probably like they host a lot of
Brands and you gave it for a different
brand and so now they're going to use it
for their other brands well like one I
just feel like that's really wasteful
like how do you know I don't hate your
stuff you know what I mean like not I'm
not defending it so I have like a policy
where I will not if you send something
to my house and I didn't give you my
address like I will not post it and I
probably won't wear it but like the boys
live stuff came in like I literally sat
in a corner for a month and then I
opened it and I was like damn like I
literally need to wear this and I became
like obsessed with the brand and I've
posted them a million times and like I
wear I bought my own stuff so that was
like a break in my policy but just
generally like as a rule I like that
really bothers me I understand that and
I'm happy for you that you got some boys
like merch um I got mine and so if it
weren't for that yeah right right no and
it's like low-key expensive like no it's
really expensive I got two sets but
thankfully one of them actually didn't
look good on me at all so it wasn't a
hard decision to send it back and save
the coin but this one suits me because
like the top is long you look great
thank you I'm feeling really cozy I have
so many errands to run today so it
wasn't going to be like a Flats tight
sort of day but somebody woke up and
said what would Jackie wear well the
thing is with our new remote setup like
what I wear like is kind kind of
irrelevant yeah which is such a relief I
cannot tell you but now we're in studio
together and like the YouTube like you
can see our whole outfit so I've been
trying to like you know put a little bit
of like my best foot forward
um and today my best foot was wearing
tights yeah no I thought you would come
in a Friday outfit because you are very
we've talked about this before like for
me I feel like Mondays I have the
hardest time getting dressed and by
Friday I figured it out and that's why
sometimes like my best on Fridays but
for you Monday you put it all in there
and then you waned through slowly lose
steam Friday it's no makeup and sweats
yeah so I was like oh Claude will be
casual today calm down like I don't
really do no makeup ever sorry
Foundation mascara and sweats no I do
the same makeup really yeah I never I
never don't have degrees no no no no I
don't have degrees no I do the same face
every day got it my outfits definitely
and my hair maybe but my face never but
your hair is beautiful you like don't
think so but you feel like you need a
blowout but you don't you welcome
control God given blowout well also I
think I'm just like coming off of the
high of like looking so stunning last
night that I kind of wanted to like keep
that energy to today yeah I feel that
let's talk about last night because we
went to we kicked off holiday season
which I'm so glad me too it's like we
were hearing Kelly Kelly Christmas we
were hearing Candy Cane Lane I heard a
new song Ava Max Christmas song shazamed
it we went to the Amazon holiday Soiree
and of course like there's so much I
want to talk about because I also like
need to drag someone to Absolute filth
but I won't do it by name influencer
studded it was influencer studded like
you know us like we like so many
influencers listen to the show so like
we're automatically friends with like a
lot of them and then there was like a
bunch of different creators like from
the Amazon influencer program who are
toasters and it was like so nice to meet
everyone
um and then there was just like other
like big time celebs like Dixie demilio
was there I didn't get a chance to chat
with Dixie did you no no but of course
my lover Tyler C was there which was
really great because Ben wasn't there
and I like I hate when they're in the
same I only had some alone time no I
hate when they're in the same room it
like makes me uncomfortable you know but
then they did end up going to dinner
together afterwards without me so that
was like kind of [ __ ] up
um but there was like a bunch of like
big time influencers there and we got to
meet someone whom I don't think like you
know it's like not your typical
influencer NYC like you don't like see
them out and about
um and we wanted to meet them and so we
went over to introduce ourselves but
mostly you because like you're a big you
know I'm a big fan and I'm big
connoisseur of their work yeah and I can
honestly no I but I can honestly say
like in my 10 years of influencing
this person was probably the rudest
person I've ever met yeah and I didn't
want to meet like I like this person's
work but that doesn't mean like I want
to meet them and be friends and or
anything like that like I actually would
not have cared to not meet them but like
Claudia knew how much like I'm in and we
were literally just talking about them
at your house like right so Claudia was
like my sister like loves him and she
loves you she has all your xyz's like
like she's just a huge fan and I don't
know if she like thought we worked for
Amazon or we're running the event or
whatever even if we were working for
Amazon like you that's how you talk to
the people who hired you for an event
right but we were behind the gift
wrapping station so right because we we
were brought to the event to be the gift
wrappers so I was like my sister she's
like nunzio and Jackie's smiling like
we're so cute and nice and funny and she
literally ignores everything we said
like literally dismissed Beyond and goes
um why was I booked for this event so
last minute and I'm like and they're
actually like were like we like I I
honestly I can't even it was so weird
that like I actually don't remember and
then where I was just like she's like
did someone drop out and then you guys
had like me come and we were like
um we I actually think we didn't say
anything we just stopped talking I said
then you were like oh no I got booked
for this I guess it was pretty last
minute too oh yeah I thought she was
like asking I was like a fellow
influencer yeah no I was like by the way
like no this is just like a week ago
like things happened so fast it's New
York baby yeah and she was like then she
turned around and she was like going on
and I was like you are [ __ ] miserable
like literally a misery and you just
would not expect that from the content
so
tea the tea is hot so funny and like who
cares if you were booked last minute
like you're here no like be grateful
like it's a fabulous party it's a
fabulous party there were so many great
gifts it actually was a perfect timed
party for the Amazon Gift guide because
now is when you should start ideating on
gifts buying gifts so that things aren't
sold out so that you're not worried
about shipping like let's get ahead of
our gift giving no and it was really
like a fun event because like all the
curlies were there we got to see like
Sophia Le scored girl boss Town Remy
everyone was there it was just really
and then we got to meet other
influencers in the wild who are toasters
which is just
it's a it's a wonderful you know to like
like Serena p and newlyweds Serena p and
Joe a thank you now she's
she was like oh my God I love the
podcast I was like what it was just
it's just like fabulous when like
everyone listens to your podcast you
know it is and they were real I don't I
don't think we met either of them before
they were so nice so sweet and just like
gorgeous married couple gorgeous married
couple and it was a gorgeous event it
really was and I'm tired but I feel
I think we can sense that yeah
it's coming through it's coming through
okay the camera like I didn't really
know how to finish the sentence you know
like I feel like tired but like I'm glad
I'm tired because like it was worth it
you know what I mean yeah it's there
should be a word for that
it's like worth no you know how in other
languages I feel like there's a lot of
this in like Swedish there's a there's
words that like we don't have for in
like there's like these feel it's
something that like gives you like
Nostalgia they're just words that don't
translate same with Yiddish that don't
translate to English words they're like
phrases or feelings Yiddish yes so if
anybody knows the Yiddish for I'm tired
but I'm glad that I'm tired because I
spend my energy on something that I
really enjoy valuable if you know the
Yiddish or the Swedish for that please
let us know just don't know in the
comments that's like you know that trend
of haggy it's Swedish it's like h a g g
a e
it's from what trend it's um it's like a
vibe I know you think I'm like speaking
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
haggis
no that's in a pudding
you guys know what I'm talking about
like everyone's gaslighting me no you're
trying to tell me about a trend I tell
you this is like a lifestyle Trend and I
actually saw a book on it in the Swedish
hug it was in like confessions of highgi
hygge is a Danish and Norwegian word
that describes a mood of coziness and
comfortable convivability with feelings
of wellness and contentment so it's like
a Vibe of like coziness I'm glad you
found it
everyone's like really big on it
everyone check it out yeah no I'm
planning on getting high GE this weekend
there was a book on Heidi in the home
section at the Amazon event last night
LOL
um so it was really just fabulous two
Fabulous Girls in New York City looking
fabulous in our dresses from Amazon and
links to shop everything in our story I
had a great time I had a great time
truly truly and now we kick off the
birthday weekend right oh my God it was
his 30th birthday yep how you feeling
I'm feeling good I'm really I can't even
tell you how much I love New York as a
tourist and I've really been thinking
about it and if I wasn't from here I
know I said this before I moved remember
we did that episode called Jackie and
NYC where I talked about like how I
would think about New York Gossip Girl
what I would do when I came if I wasn't
from this town like I would be obsessed
with it and I think about like all the
books that I read like I'm obsessed with
historical New York so I would come here
I would go to Morgan Library I would
want to see the plaza like everything
all the history and I just I love this
city when I don't live here no I I feel
that for you 100 especially like this is
the most gorgeous week most gorgeous
time of year the leaves in the park are
changing it's not even cold it's not
even hot it's Perfection like I have no
regrets about moving if anything this
makes me feel even better it's like now
I can have a good relationship with New
York yeah you and New York can get back
on on a good spotting yeah but it's so
crazy because I'm sure if I grew up in a
a like in the suburbs or in a small town
my whole life I would and I was obsessed
with New York like because I am I would
want to move here so bad it would be
like here after college and I would be
obsessed with it and then people would
say no New York's going in the gutter I
would say never no you'd be one of those
it's it's so The Grass Is Always Greener
and now because I grew up in the city
I'm like I just want nature yep yep and
that's what you have you always want
what you don't have 100 so just like
realize that and then be happy where you
are Bloom where you're playing You Can't
Always Get What You Want
Bloom where you're planted Bloom where
you're planting how do you feel about
New York I feel like so amazing about
New York I feel
so
good
you have highgy
can we move on like for real I'm not
okay what do you want to move on to the
show this is the show no like the show
the meat and potatoes this this is my
meat and potatoes and I think that's
where we have creative differences oh my
God please not now I'm really not okay
like for real you'll be fine I think I
have an illness like yeah it's called
get a coffee I can't drink coffee
your efforts failed on Starbucks no it's
just like coffee like it's like a fun
little accoutrement like it's an
accessory to me at this point but it's
not
like an energizing beverage for me okay
you know
Okay so we've got a great show we've got
five stories no TV recap you know a lot
of people are starting conspiracy
theories about us again because we
haven't recapped Kardashians in like
three weeks and people think there's
like something going on
no um this is what's going on the last
few episodes that I watched were not
good enough for me to prioritize
watching the next few and whenever I
have the time which I have absolutely
zero of when I do get more time I'm
gonna watch the crown um and then after
that
um I would watch Kardashians but like to
watch it week to week and like sit at
the edge of my seat like it just wasn't
giving and I forgot I legit forgot about
it 100 I of course the season began and
I was like ooh episode the first episode
was amazing it was maybe too good
because everything else like gave
nothing after that I went back to being
commercials and one thing about me yeah
is like I am a Kardashian apologist
through and through blind loyal fan
but to a point and honestly like this
season
is bad yeah and that doesn't mean I
don't love the girls as much as I do but
I have to at some point like start being
honest with myself yeah and it would be
good to watch like you know in the
background on a Sunday as you're like
doing something else to watch like
episode after episode but for me to like
sit down at like 9 00 p.m I have like
three hours to myself in the evening and
that's not how I want to spend one of
them no it's really it's not good so
that's why that's why also I was gonna
say one more thing but I don't want to
upset you what
I finished my book oh good
the princess spy it's non-fiction about
a spy I'll be really quick I mean it's
fine yeah and you can relax you know
just talk about
um this woman in World War II who was a
spy for
um the USA in Madrid and she did some
covert missions she wound up falling in
love with a count over there and her
name Luanne the Countess of Romanov this
is a true story and she went on to be
like a fabulous lady and she just passed
away in 2017.
Countess yeah the best part about
reading a non-fiction book is it feels
it's like it's going by really slowly
and then at 60 you're done because that
the rest is like footnotes so I thought
I was gonna I thought I was just reading
so slow because I was bored because it
wasn't like the best read ever but it
was it was cute whatever I have so many
books I'm so excited to read so I'll
leave it at that and I'll catch you up
on them on Monday 100 or you know on the
redheads the new episode just dropped
yesterday Jackie's podcast exclusively
about books that I hadn't finished the
princess spy before we recorded I guess
the redheaders will have to wait till
next month yeah but by then I won't care
that's the problem it's not a perfect
system it's it's not maybe you should
Drop Like weekly episodes on the
redheads like just talking about like
books you're reading like solo like a
snackable yeah I think I think
yeah well gum now without further Ado
from me and me alone here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you embark on a wonderful weekend
today's episode is brought to you by the
match dating app do you do you match the
dating app is pretty hot and bothered
about this topic understandably it's a
juicy one match believes the most
important relationship is with yourself
so in a world where you can choose to do
anything or do anyone choose you first
because dating someone who knows what
they want and won't settle for less that
is sexy as hell if you're up if you are
over the people in your life who are
just like not doing it for you when it
comes to dating here are some
Alternatives why don't you just be your
own best friend with benefits I don't
really feel like you should be entering
the dating space first until like you
really are in love with yourself because
in the words of RuPaul if you can't love
yourself how in the hell are you going
to love somebody else
um but also like what's more attractive
to someone than like someone who knows
their worth and knows their value and is
that content being alone and naturally
encourages people to do that before
going out and onto the dating scene
um so if you are sick of like taking
people out to dinner and like listening
to their boring stories like take
yourself out to dinner because you don't
have to listen to anyone's stories you
could literally just scroll Tick Tock or
read a book or just like judge and sit
other people sit and judge other people
which is one of my favorite activities
to do especially in New York or just say
look and pretend like you're in a music
video oh my God that's my second
favorite thing to do like I'm literally
the star of a music video
um
sorry I disrupted you you did you did
um so if you do you you already know the
best relationships show up when you show
up for yourself first there's never been
a better time to try match you could
download the match app today I know a
million people who have had immense
major success on the match dating app
um I highly recommend it they highly
recommend it and match is just looking
out for you you know and for that we
appreciate them
today's episode is also brought to you
by verst skin is complicated but skin
care should not be and that's where
verse comes in with their clean results
driven products at drugstore prices from
ethically sourced ingredients
to ethically sourced ingredients to
recycled packaging versus products are
developed for you with you and with our
planet in mind so
um I actually have been using verst one
was the Spritz
brunch
so the summer because it's right May
2022. so there was a girl there who was
like telling me she does like skincare
and Beauty content and I was like well
what is like your number one product
because your skin is amazing she was
like
um when you take off your makeup use a
cleansing balm and I love the one from
verse it's like eucalyptus and I ordered
it at the brunch and now I'm on like my
third container of it makeup bombs are
so in right now and the one from birth
uses like really great ingredients I
wear waterproof mascara I wear a lot of
makeup and it comes off so well and then
I just fell down a rabbit hole of like
versus products and now I'm definitely
averse girly because their form formulas
are
formulated to the highest standards in
the world they use safe effective
ingredients at skin changing levels
think retinol and vitamin C but at a
fraction of the cost of high-end skin
care all of burst is cruelty free vegan
Dermatology tested and sensitive skin
friendly it is sustainable at the heart
of everything that they do from using
post-consumer recycled materials in
their packaging to maintaining a net
zero climate emission chances are you've
seen verse pop up on your Tick Tock or
your Instagram feed from the viral glass
skin delivered by the instant
resurfacing mask to their new gentle
retinol body lotion that's already sold
out three times it is the brand clean
Beauty fans can't get enough of you can
visit birthtoskin.com toast and use code
toast at checkout for 10 off your
purchase that's burst skin
v-e-r-s-e-d skin.com slash toast and use
code toast t-o-a-s-t at checkout for 10
off your purchase that that's burst skin
b-e-r-s-e-d dot skin skin.com toast
verstskin.com toast code toast love I
love the vacation I under eyes yes gel I
use that on my skincare routine and the
lip oil which I'm wearing right now with
a little lip liner and lip oil stunning
new favorite combo stunning first story
Nick Cannon is expecting baby number 11
his second with model Alyssa Scott it's
quote a miracle and a blessing Nick
Cannon is adding another baby to his
brood the actor is expecting his 11th
baby his second with Alyssa Scott they
share Sun Zen who died at five months
old in December of 2021.
on Thursday Alyssa shared a series of
intimate photos with Canon from the
Paris maternity shoot together in the
pictures uh they're both naked in a
bathtub as the musician cradles her baby
bump and she captioned it this is a
miracle and a blessing I'm happy for her
you know that she's pregnant again a
rainbow baby
um do you see the photos no I didn't
show them would you like to
kind of cute I kind of love that no like
obsessed I thought it was going to be
like tacky but yeah because they're like
naked yeah naked in a bathtub is a
little weird
um but the execution is really gorgeous
no it's giving art yeah and it's new
there are only so many ways to
announcement poses you can do I've not
seen this I think they look amazing yeah
let's talk about
um because obviously a child is a
blessing happy for them
um but this is his 11th child and you
know a lot of people are now weighing in
because this is really kind of crazy
um weighing in that he has like a
what's it called like a kink for
procreating is that a thing
some psychologists on Instagram were
saying that it is psychologists will say
anything about anything no I know but
like it is like a lot of kids it is a
lot of kids all I would wonder is like
what kind of father he is to the other
ten well the thing is it's like when you
have children with different women you
can really only give so much of your
time to each family like so it's just
but maybe he is you know he's also like
a
a person with a job like
there's really only so much time you can
give to kids in different homes when
you're also like a huge star yeah so
like I think there are elements of it
that are like maybe it's like enough
kids for real
um because I think like 11 kids is still
is way too much in
with one person
you know it's like you can really only
give so much of your time love and
attention to 12 people including your
partner so it's 11 kids and then the
mothers I don't know how many mothers
there are I think it's like four or five
Oh I thought it's um one two three four
yeah so it's just like it's a lot and
don't forget Mariah Carey oh my God like
the Mariah Carey being one like that's
crazy
um and other kids are 11 years old I
don't know like for me like a baby's
always a blessing but like enough is
also enough yeah there's two sets of
twins in there
okay well that helps bring it down so
it's like nine nine births ten with um
the baby Zion yeah okay so maybe like so
like conceptions yeah it's just um
it was like a it's like a funny joke
like people are like Nick Cannon like
there's so many babies but like why does
he have so many babies like for real I
know I would I would just love to hear
his philosophy I don't know maybe he's
like I think he has a podcast maybe he's
spoken about it like maybe he loves his
kids maybe his older kids are getting
older and he loves babies and loves
being a father like I would love to just
hear him speak on it like
and understand why he has so many kids
and like what kind of father he is you
know yeah yeah all of his kids would be
like Nick is the best daddy in the world
like and they're all like happy and like
then the more the merrier no that's fair
that's a fair statement so that's why I
asked like I just wonder what kind of
dad he is and what his philosophy is on
having kids and if like he just happens
to keep getting pregnant because maybe
he's like against contraception right or
if he's like intentionally getting
pregnant because he loves being a father
and he wants more kids and he loves
family I don't know it's um
it's definitely you know bizarre it's
Unique it's Unique New York I feel like
people who have this many kids get a
reality show 19 kids encounter I feel
like you have to have 12 kids to apply
to TLC I don't think they'll take
anything less than 12. it's not I don't
know they just took on the Culpo show
and there's three girls so but the
interest comes from other places you
guys who's so [ __ ] no John and Kate
Plus Eight I think eight is probably the
minimum and octo mom eight yeah okay
eight so if you ever really won a
reality show you gotta have eight kids
well I really don't want to have any
kids and I really don't want a reality
show so I'm so good but that's a message
to all you out there yeah looking for a
reality show get pregnant eight times or
with um octuplets Octomom yeah but
that's not safe no it's not no did octo
mom tell it no she didn't no I don't
think so I was actually just reading
about her recently she was like in the
news for something now was she yeah
um a few months ago but I I that that's
when I learned because I hadn't thought
about or realized before that like
carrying eight is like impossible this
is impossible and it's unhealthy so what
ended up happening because I saw a
picture of her like fully pregnant
the most famous she has 14 children
oh
maybe she did give birth
yeah I need her Wikipedia yeah you know
does actor mom have a Wikipedia she does
she really does her mom's full name
children her name is Nadia Solomon let's
start putting some respect on her name
yeah
uh
um is there an Octodad fraternal twins
she did IVF
so she intentionally had eight babies or
no she was married in 1996 and then in
1997 she started IVF IVF in 2000 they
separated and in 2008 2006 they filed
for divorce no I want to know about the
babies if they meant the babies
separated
what happened with the eight babies oh
great that's what I'm reading now okay
in 2009 she said she had six embryos
left over from her previous IVF
treatment she explained that she
requested Okay blah blah blah
no [ __ ] clue
she's 14 kids it sounds like she gave
birth to all eight
such a good episode I was like no like
we can get out of the silence I guess I
could find this another day where are
you write in the comments if you already
know or if you go find it but sorry that
was like really confusing there's a lot
of embryos going on not Wikipedia doing
the least and then like asking for money
you know Wikipedia like always out here
like with their handout for like a
dollar like we have some pride
like in high school I would like write
my whole paper on Wikipedia and like not
be able to use them as a source I'm like
you didn't even help me and like I want
you want me to give you money yeah it's
like you're literally
run some ads or some [ __ ] like get like
a business strategist like why is
Wikipedia always asking for money like
we're a man for profit uh why run some
ads like do you know how many ways there
are to make money on the internet how
many clicks to Wikipedia get today
billions they're missing out on billions
of dollars no like literally start a
podcast like do something and like
seriously like stop sitting out with
your handout like it's embarrassing like
if you really want people to pay for
your platform then put it behind a
paywall and if you really want people to
pay for your platform how about this
like why don't you change the policy
where people can start citing you in
their High School term papers and then
maybe I'll give you the dollar Wikipedia
policy that's a your teacher policy no
if Wikipedia could figure it out is fake
as [ __ ] if Wikipedia can figure it out I
would give you a dollar but I just want
to say it would go against their whole
model here's something I'm extremely
proud of
I have literally used Wikipedia many
times in my life and I've never given
them a scent and I never will okay
I'm gonna give my money to a worthy
cause okay like the Red Cross or Gift of
Life
okay thank you for that PSA I was
thinking about that as I fell asleep the
other day like somebody I wanted to talk
about on the toes like why are they
always asking for money like for real
it's embarrassing for them it is
embarrassing and who's donating no and
it's like who has donated to Wikipedia
found off in the comments no don't
because that's like I'm embarrassed for
you like the way and I'm sure people
like Claudia Wikipedia actually helps a
lot of people I'm sure they do but I'm
still gonna make fun of them because
like when you think about like Mark
Zuckerberg like his platform is
literally just as big as Wikipedia and
he like what do you get fined for like
56 billion dollars the other day and
like it was nothing like in the bucket
yeah so it's like how are there like
Mark zuckerbergs and the men who started
Wikipedia like hold on I bet you the man
by the way I bet you the man who started
Wikipedia lives on the street like for
real who started Wikipedia somebody who
obviously has no business Acumen Larry
Sanger and Jimmy Wales oh let me guess
actually they live on a private island
and their business is asking for money
for people on the street like
uh that's just one of the things in the
world that like it's one of the great
wonders to me like how Wikipedia is
always needing money
yeah oh wait wait and Jackie no no okay
and what do they need money for they
literally people on the internet update
Wikipedia Pages for free yeah they don't
have employees they must not because
people are always going into Wikipedia
and being like actually Abe Lincoln's
beard was cut in 1971 not 197 or two
yeah so it's like you want money from
the people and then you also put the
people to work yeah
it's genius
it's literal like what I don't even know
what the word is it's like not communism
it's like
it's like you're stealing from the
people
and also making the people work for you
yeah
it's Savory stealing from people they're
asking I just I actually I need a
documentary on Wikipedia because there's
something I'm right there I agree
something ain't [ __ ] right
you're on to something okay I'm so glad
we spoke about that like not you asking
me for money and then also putting me to
work
yeah you know um I actually have a
Wikipedia account okay because I oh wait
no yeah I wanted to um update some of
the the facts on the Fresco Wikipedia
page and every time I would like go in
this like [ __ ] from Sweden like would
undo my work
she literally I would delete and she
would go and like I literally was
getting to a fight with this [ __ ] and
then they locked the Wikipedia page and
you can't edit the Fresco Wikipedia page
anymore
let's go look yeah no you really can't
let's go because I just added that
celebrity influencer and podcaster
Claudia ashrae is obsessed with Fresca
and she like soon hopes to have a Fresca
soda machine installed in her home one
day and this [ __ ] kept taking it out
like I wasn't relevant enough for
Wikipedia really really
my username was like you know what
actually give me your no you can view
the history through the history okay
wait what oh wow there's a lot of
editing give me give me okay oh my God I
forgot I did this I'm like such a freak
sometimes no not 2022. you take your
time I'm gonna figure out what I haven't
talked online
let's let's just sit here in silence and
and Google okay older than 50. wow
people have been updating it a lot in
2022
okay let me think about when I did this
it must have been
in 2019.
she did Welcome octuplets
okay did you know that there's actually
peanut butter in Fresca no I wonder why
I love it so much did you know that
Octomom was already mom to six children
when she gave birth to eight little ones
I think the hardest part about having so
many kids would be knowing what to name
them 100 by the way
unidentified sperm donor for Octomom oh
my God so Octodad is just walking around
this planet
yeah oh my God
no it wasn't 2017.
oh my there's also corn cheese in Fresca
that's disgusting
I mean not people fighting about
politics in the Fresca
because you know William Taft was like
obsessed with Fresca but where his
politics like unsavory right and like
someone said that Linda B Johnson is a
dumbass like people really genuinely
like need to get a life like we're the
ones reading it no wait I need to find
my back and forth fight with this girl
Wiki user
dating maintenance oh in popular culture
wow she delivered eight kids she's a
hero oh my God today's episode is just
gonna be called like research and
development like you want to watch us
research dumb [ __ ]
oh and one of her kids is a vegan
wow healthy lifestyle that's huge she's
been photographed with raw vegetables
and beet juice all over his face as a
kid I can't remember I'm [ __ ] crazy
but that's in this article I genuinely
cannot remember I don't know Scruples my
username oh [ __ ] I locked the iPad oh
God what's your password I think I know
got it okay
um I think my username was like smashly
like I was like making [ __ ] up like you
know
yeah because like I was gonna be adding
in information about myself so I
couldn't be like you know Claudia ashrae
added Claudia the gorgeous Instagram
star you know
I feel like a lot of other podcasts and
we never really like we Google stuff
sometimes but if we don't find the
answer in two seconds we move on but
other podcasts like do sit and look for
the stuff and
it's much more slow paced so why not us
[Music]
I got the answers I was looking for I
didn't
maybe this would be a good time to tell
you about the books I'm excited okay
let's move on
no but this is gonna be really good I'll
post a screenshot of my want to read
list for sure
um happy Friday Canon happy for Nick
Conan he should call Octomom 100 he
should call octo mom next up some more
family news the official best Halloween
costume of 2022 has arrived and it's
Beyonce and Jay-Z's family as the proud
family Proud Family
Beyonce and Jay-Z treated fans to a rare
family snap from this year's Halloween
celebrations in which they were decked
out in costumes from the Disney Channel
animated show the pre the proud family
it's amazing um Beyonce posted it and
captioned it from family every single
day and night and Beyonce is dressed as
sugar mama and as Trudy Parker so I
guess there's like a little Photoshop
happening and Blue Ivy was dressed as
Penny Proud while her siblings remain
sir were both dressed as CeCe proud and
BB proud respectively no like Blue Ivy
is Penny Proud this is it's a perfect
costume the perfect costumes well
executed it's a brilliant idea it's you
know on the nose and pop culture it's
Perfection and if you told me like
Beyonce is going to be Sugar Mama for
Halloween like you would say did she put
her foot in it
and she did she put her foot she put her
whole foot into this whole costume and
so did the whole family even her doing
double duty and photoshopping herself
and on the other side we love a queen
who knows how to use Adobe and it's like
not a crazy photo shoot you know the
entire uh Terry Richardson it's not
embarrassingly formal right like it's a
little pick art you know little word art
yeah it's it's adorable and she wins
wins who did we have as like the winner
previously before Beyonce for this year
yeah there was someone that we liked
yeah but like who did we say
the father-daughter
Dion from Clueless oh sorry I actually
still think they win
it's tied but he wins okay you're all
winners
are you ready for a little more family
they'll push your buttons
I don't think that's how it goes isn't a
proud family reboot or reunion coming
soon something we reported on it but I
don't know if it ever came out not yet
but I think it's in the works maybe the
answer is melt
I'm sorry I'm giving like nothing today
I want to apologize to everyone but I've
been just been giving my all like to
everything and I'm sorry I just I feel
like guilty that I'm being like so bad
on the show you know what you need to do
you need to listen to your body
and take a break 100
. well you're trying to get me to run
errands with you after this and it's
just like not gonna happen that's not
what I was trying to do yeah you were
don't mislead the audience that's what
you're trying oh and you like give me a
job you're like hey can you do my
laundry like I couldn't make it easier
for you I brought it to you and then I'm
going to you're coming to me later so
like you can say no but is it Harry's
Laundry it's a mixture of ours is it
exact sturdy just me and Harry okay fine
with me can I watch them separately or
together all together just throw it all
in are you ready for our next story I
genuinely am Aaron Paul has filed to
legally change his seven month old son's
first and middle names so seven months
after welcoming his Bebe Boy Aaron Paul
has reportedly filed a petition to
change the little one's name while the
infant's legal name on his birth
certificate is Casper Emerson Paul has
publicly referred to him as Ryder
Caspian since his arrival in March and
thus they are changing it to Ryder
Caspian he said that we were required to
give a name at the hospital and went
with Casper Emerson but
um
we came up with a better more suitable
name and we're going to change it so I
feel like now it was like a good time
like this is open the door for me to
have a conversation with you I know I
know what you're gonna say I could
change so Harry's name on his birth
certificate is Harrison but nobody calls
him that no and like honestly like it's
so not him right now he's a Herald or
just a Harry like I don't know seeing
stuff like this it's like
it's not that big of a deal I wonder
what the process is I could look into it
but then it's like
his name is still Harry no matter how
you slice it no for sure and like you
have all this like memorabilia all these
like tchotchkes like people got you
aunts uncle's grandparents like chairs
and toys and things but like the way I
don't know Harrison I don't know
Harrison wine Rabb if he smacked me
between the eyes but oh Harry weinrib
yeah no I know him I [ __ ] with Harry
wine rep he's literally my best friend
no I know I know so I just think like
maybe this is a sign like if Aaron
Paul's doing it Kylie's obviously doing
it like what if Jackie O did it just
think about it I will think about it it
might have to be in a few months because
I just got his passports I have to like
wait till I get the passport and then
like how are you going somewhere Harry
is an international traveler is he
leaving the country anytime soon he will
be so it'd have to be after that oh
right right it would have to be after
that trip so I could get a new like 100
when I'm gonna be here for a while yeah
it's gonna be Stateside for a while oh
not you the jet Setter yeah no I'll be
Stateside for q1
q1 but who knows what could happen in Q2
you know I was talking to someone last
night and I was like oh when is like
something happening and they were like
Q4
oh my God you need to get a grip like
like are we on Zoom Q4 I'm like just
tell me what it is
we're in Q4 of next year oh yeah yeah it
was just like okay it was Tyler I do
like the cues though it was Tyler it's a
nice way to break up the year it was
Tyler c yeah
so like it was fine because like when he
said it he was like Q4 hey I want to get
in bed with me and I was like oh okay
let me get Theo yeah so I wasn't like
that upset about it
I'm really not okay like no and I like
not to put pressure on you but like we
kind of have a big weekend so you should
really rest up after that's what I'm
trying to do no after this honestly like
and this is like a serious conversation
like today would have been a day like if
I had a typical job like I might have
taken like a mental health because I'm
not sick but I just don't feel like my
best like I feel like I could burst into
tears at any moment you know
um but I put you know we put this show
on our backs and I feel like every day
we miss a show it's like I hate it yeah
I hate to miss a show and people are
saying yeah I never knew yeah like I
hate to miss a show but today like I
woke up and my body was off like I feel
unbalanced and somebody like you're
pregnant I have my period okay [ __ ] off
I'm not pregnant okay okay good thing
the next two stories are
brought to you by Sprint Society oh my
God something that always makes me feel
balanced and by the way we have huge
sports news we do so tell them what you
got to tell them and then I'll share my
piece so Spirit Society is a canned
cocktail beverage company that is very
close to our hearts because we literally
started it our whole family is involved
we've got amazing people involved in the
company as you guys know dear media and
Michael Bostic are recent investors
we've got professional athletes we kind
of have like a sickening like actually
Forbes just like wrote about us like
we're kind of killing it
um and so we know the toasters have been
so supportive of our brand and we're so
appreciative but we wanted to tell you
that support Society in case you are new
here is an all-natural recognizable
ingredients no I [ __ ] I just really
botched that whole thing let me start
over Ben is going to kill me
do it again
Sports Society takes all-natural
recognizable ingredients and packs them
into a convenient sparkling canned
cocktail that makes you that you can
take anywhere
they're low calorie low sugar drinks
with six percent ABV that are guaranteed
delicious if you don't want to take our
word for it know that Spritz Society was
just named the best canned cocktail by
USA Today it comes in five iconic
flavors to choose from grapefruit blood
orange Peach which we have right here
pineapple and lemon so you really can't
go wrong so Peach is our newest flavor
it is slow quickly becoming a crowd
favorite it's definitely one of my
favorite it actually tastes like a
Snapple I'm personally a grapefruit
girly you can actually shop on the
website right now um our favorite
flavors like we're selling them as
bundles
um if you're interested to know and what
we like the best
and if you don't know what to try first
you can just get the variety pack which
has eight cans of the four original
flavors which doesn't include Peach but
all the other flavors and then you can
add Peach to your cart to complete the
whole set so why people love Spritz
again is because it's all natural like
if you read the ingredients on the back
like it's literal English it's not like
crazy malt and that's why we started
this company because like if you love
heart seltzers but they like have been
starting to [ __ ] with you I can't drink
hard tilters like I gave me diarrhea one
time my stomach was in so much pain it's
literally full of chemicals like this is
actually like just like ingredients you
know natural ingredients recognize
that's where the recognizable
ingredients so I obviously we have a
code for you guys because uh you can try
the iconic sparkling cocktails for 10
off by using Code toast at
spritzociety.com it's code toast for 10
off at
spritzsociety.com
spritzociety.com s-p-r-i-t-z society.com
use code toast and
and in honor of my birthday this weekend
the collab of the century
Spritz X say it again you [ __ ] it up
with your throat
Spritz X redheads oh yeah Spritz and the
redheads are collabing for a sickening
giveaway for my birthday so this
giveaway there will be three winners
each winner will win a signed Kindle
that's pre-loaded with my five favorite
books then also each book will pair with
a four pack of Spritz a book per flavor
and it is going on starting today
probably once this episode drops it will
be live on Instagram the way that you
enter I'll just tell you guys now but
it's all the info is on the Spritz and
redheads
caption on Instagram but you'll fill out
the link in the Spritz bio you'll like
and tag two bookworms in the comments
and you'll get an extra entry when you
re-share to your stories and you must be
21 plus and based in the US we'll share
the winners on my birthday and that's
such a good giveaway yeah it's a great
giveaway and the potatoes are like my
premium truly my five favorite books so
if you're a new reader it's a great way
to get into reading if you've been
reading hardcovers and you're ready for
a Kindle like enter if sometimes you
want to back up kindle in your life
enter I do have a backup candle because
Jackie was so generous and gave me her
backup Kindle well her Backup backup
Kindle yeah and it's really nice because
then I gave it to Ben and like if my
other one dies it's nice so it's the
Kindle Paperwhite which we love it's the
best Kindle out there I agree and it's
going to be a great giveaway so check it
out on at Spritz and at the redheads and
use kotos if you're just looking for
some Beverages and you don't even know
how to read them yeah and you don't want
to yeah because [ __ ] Wikipedia yeah and
their corporate agenda do you ever find
your edits no I will find them though I
need to come through
I need to do it on a computer
next story Johnny Depp will make a guest
appearance in Rihanna's Savage X Fenty
show Rihanna has reportedly Enlisted the
help of a very prominent a-lister to
make her upcoming Savage X venti volume
4 show the buzziest one yet Johnny will
be gracing the stage at The Lift Me Up
Hit makers upcoming show on November 9th
debuting on Prime video
sources told TMZ that the 59 year old
actor will not be shredding down the
runway but instead will feature in the
show's star moments which previously saw
the likes of Cindy Crawford and Erica
Badu making cameos who will be the first
male to do so
I'm so confused
because
one how do these two know each other two
you know there are there's so much
weirdness around the Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp thing because obviously like
the
the verdicting the verdict came down and
like awarded Johnny
period but like that's like not been
enough for some people and I think like
there was paperwork that came out
afterwards that was like proving Johnny
was abusive like I don't know exactly
um and
so we know that but I feel like a lot of
people forget like Rihanna went through
like a really public domestic violence
thing with Chris Brown
um so it's like she's a victim of
domestic violence and like they're the
jury like actually the jury is not out
but like people still think like Johnny
Depp was abusive and like like I don't
think that maybe Rihanna sees Johnny
Depp as a victim of domestic violence
that's what I think but it's just like
it's so this is so I was like I had to
reread this headline like five times
when I saw it yesterday on Instagram I
was like what yeah apparently the
article says that uh it was Rihanna's
idea to have him in the show
yes like maybe she you know recognized
in him
something she once saw in herself that's
like a like a connection but yeah that's
interesting I hadn't realized that
connection I thought that maybe like you
know Johnny Depp he's having a moment
like and people really love him right
now no because like and she's really on
top of like the trends and whoever's the
IT person of the moment like is always
in her shows or attending and so maybe
she was like
I think it's deeper than that no that's
a good point that you raised yeah but
like I'm still confused because like I'm
not sure like where we as a society
landed with Johnny Depp no he is
exonerated like I think not in
everyone's eyes no I guess there's stuff
going around on Tick Tock documents I
haven't seen anything but I would say
like both of them hired
incredibly thorough legal teams the
trial was incredibly thorough there was
no stone left unturned if there were
documents that would have proven Amber's
innocence all along right how they just
mysteriously turn up
um we waited till they went through due
process and Johnny has been exonerated
and he should after some movies like at
whatever Hiatus everyone put him on put
him on Ice while they waited to find out
like he should be back to business as
usual no I agree
and I think maybe Rihanna would agree
with you too yeah because she's putting
him to work was officially uncanceled
right
no it's uh it's an interesting point
are you ready for our fifth and final
story already I was just starting to
like feel better
usually the toast does rehabilitate you
I know but I'm telling you there's like
something to Bissell off with me today
okay and I apologize to everyone I
really do but like even you know
Superstar comedians have bad days real
house is Beverly Hills Mauricio umanski
explains why his new series buying
Beverly Hills is an on Bravo that's a
valid question it is I hadn't thought
about it but it's like I'm surprised
that Bravo didn't make a show about the
human skis sooner or like if someone
like a production company had the idea
to make a show about the umanskis and
then went and shopped it around like
shouldn't like the right thing to do
like be bringing it to Bravo at least
first give them like the option to
reviews right because also that would be
good for the show in the audience yeah
but actually when it came time for
Mauricio's powerful La real estate
company the agency to launch its own
reality show and many assumed it would
be on Bravo
um Mauricio explained why it was not it
had all to do with his company being
quote a global brand he said we have 60
offices we're in the middle of growing
we're continuing to grow we're now in
Europe we actually just opened up in
Amsterdam which is where Netflix has
their headquarters in Europe Netflix is
a global brand as well it just made all
the sense to be on Netflix it sounds
like he's saying he's literally too big
for Bravo yeah and you know what like
Netflix is much bigger than Bravo and
even though it might feel like a slight
that Bravo passed on his show it's like
maybe Bravo wanted it and Netflix wanted
it and he's like we're going with
Netflix no maybe they didn't even take
it to Netflix I mean to Bravo yeah
sounds like they had bigger and better
ideas for it it's not like his show
ended up on oxygen no and they've been
on this um LOL
um they've been on Bravo for so long and
like they know like the ratings even for
a good season like they go down every
year like cable is very much a thing of
them past so they know firsthand how
Netflix you can't even compare the
number of people who watch selling
Sunset to the people who watch um
Million Dollar Listings right
agreed also this is great for both
audiences
um I think if Mauricio is has is really
successful and people love the show that
will make them want to watch Beverly
Hills and see more bits of Mauricio and
his family that's true and this will
also make Beverly Hills Watchers want to
go to Netflix and see Mauricio they love
him yeah this is a rising Tides raise
all shied situation it's a horizon
United situation I couldn't couldn't
have said it better myself yeah and good
for him like Netflix is massive I hope
the show does really well and and they
love a glitzy reality show glitzy Rich
Beverly Hills yeah it's agreed so it'll
be cool thank you for putting up with me
today and kind of carrying the show I'm
really not okay and I hate to like keep
bringing it up I just want to let her
know like I'm normally so funny like
this is your first episode like come
back on Monday come back on Monday and
like I'm gonna give you everything I've
got
can't wait and by the time we come back
on Monday Jackie will be back in Florida
which is so [ __ ] sad and I'll be 30.
and you'll be 30 and it's like what do
you think that's gonna look like
I think it will be the same because they
think I'm ready to turn 30. you know
um
ready to turn 30. I think you're ready
to to me honestly you are 30. like the
fact that you're 29 like you're so young
do you know what I mean yeah like you're
29 like you have a baby and like a house
but what's so crazy is like compared to
the rest of human history like I have
I'm 29 I have one baby Jackie if you
like start comparing your life to like
timeline to human history like you have
a problem yeah but things are also
different than human history you know
people are living longer yeah I just
don't think that's like a good you know
like they did in the BCS yeah no it's
not a good limit it's no I'm I'm not
complaining I'm just saying it's just
it's just like because it sounded like
you were complaining no no it's just
funny how times change so much like yes
a hundred years ago if I was 29
like if I got married at 26 it's like
Old Maid uh who's the old maid even you
married at 23. spinster we didn't know
if she was gonna make it it's so true
um well that's our show
and hope you guys have an amazing
weekend thank you so much for listening
to the Joe simulator
YouTube please don't forget the video
games on Spotify
listen to podcasts find us the toast and
leave a five-star view about how quickly
talented we are wickedly hope you guys
have an amazing weekend stay safe get
lit wish Jackie O A Happy Birthday on
Sunday and we'll see you back on Monday
bye